we get into our first yeah Ori uh Red
Dead Redemption two special editions
have been revealed and you can pre-order
them now we haven't seen gameplay yet we
know we've definitely like and I mean
real gameplay of like right this is what
its gonna look like when you play it but
I yeah I there's a lot here man we've
got the special edition which is 80
bucks and you get like a bunch of stuff
you get like bank-robbery mission a gang
hideout mission for like the single
player so that's all single-player stuff
that's all single-player stuff okay um
yep
have they said anything about online I
don't think they have there isn't there
isn't online but we know nothing about
it everyone's assuming it's gonna be
heavily inspired by GTA online insanely
popular I've been that I don't really
know much about it yeah it'll be
interesting to see because obviously
they don't want to like eat into GTA
online but you also get a horse you get
a dapple the black thoroughbred what if
you didn't get a horse at all unless you
pre-ordered like you got oh yeah yeah
it's it's it's um yeah well I mean you
thankfully you don't even have to
preorder it to get this horse because
they can be obtained like you can get a
horse in the game holy cow what so it
can is this a breed you can only get by
peering Oriole I know it's it and the
saddle you get the Nuevo Paraiso saddle
which is a place I like to drop in pub G
perfect they can both be obtained just
in story mode
oh so this is just basically you're
getting that it's like a little media
skip ahead yeah for sure okay you also
get in-game items like the Eagle Talon
and the iguana scale which will
basically like Arthur takes less damage
and makes Arthur's environmental
awareness last longer right and it's
starting to make me think like what is
this game yeah won't the uh once you put
the trailer oh yeah let's pull up the
trailer here it is so this is this is
not a new trailer no no yeah but we'd
like it's its god there's so much here
there's extra weapons
you get a bunch of stuff I have to
imagine these weapons are also in the
game I can't volcanic pistol pump-action
yeah do you remember like the gold
weapons mm-hmm from the first game yeah
and you just looked awful yeah really
I'm typically not a fan of gold plated
weapons in my game very rarely do I
think it looks good yeah I and also like
I also tricked my friend into giving me
all of his pre-order stuff for free
mm-hm
I feel bad about that we don't really
don't look at the chat but I saw Josh
mentions is am i from Canada I'm
actually not from Canada but everyone
thinks I'm from Canada because of my
name you're from Canada to me I'm from
Vermont which is basically Canada right
but yeah then there's also the Ultimate
Edition and the collectors box the
Ultimate Edition includes everything
from special edition bonus outfits
another a different horse
so you can choose oh sweet I read both
at the same time I wish you could do
like the Jean Claude Van Damme you get a
theme a survivor camp theme which is I'm
not sure what that is I'm guessing that
is like it there's a lot of
customization it seems like based on
this these these notes like you have
items that increase your defense you
have right you have different horses
different outfits which were present in
the previous game but this sounds like
you are going to actually be able to
customize your survivor camp as well
which is which is interesting and also
there's a their rank bonuses which are
basically you can rank up faster online
and all that good stuff and also there's
like oh hey you can for this is for the
single-player you'll get more money when
you do bank robbery missions and whatnot
or you'll do you'll get more money for
selling skins or so there does seem to
be like a little like hey you wanna you
want to jump ahead and make more money
doing less pre-order of the game
hmm yeah yeah I'm always kind of
whatever about that do you want me to
play less of your game like paying it's
like that mobile game thing where you
can pay money to play less of the game
if you want yeah and then I kind of
makes me question the economy I feel
like well am i spending too much time
like if I try playing normally like am I
gonna take like way too much time where
it doesn't feel worth it so yeah weird
and we're gonna pull up the the
collectors box here it is over there oh
look at that
Oh actually why don't you want you right
click right click or click for me and
hit open image and use that oh heck yeah
there we go
and now hit on hit f11 oh yeah I'm
teaching Matt how to use computers now
hit f11 one more time there we go okay
I'm alright let's go to that right there
oh look at that box in Edel it's a metal
tipping box I don't even know what TIF
thing is but it's got a lock in a key in
it you want to keep it safe it's got a
cat like a bunch of like in-world things
it's got a puzzle if you're into puzzles
I know all of my Red Dead Redemption fan
friends are hella into puzzles but yeah
this this is is is one heck of a
collector's box and I'm actually going
to check the price for you right now it
is it does not say our story does not
say that what the box costs but anyway
poni matters it's a lot of stuff it's
$100 $100 I don't think that's right I'm
gonna take a look at right here so it
says on your notes we're opening up I
think those notes may be wrong $2
dollars for the collectors buggies that
is crazy I thought for sure they were
gonna go like nuts with like here's a
200 dollar box you want it you want to
put your game in the box that's
relatively to hide your drugs in this
metal Tiffin box absolutely I do
yeah for sure I don't need you because
I'm in California don't need a hide my
dress right cuz cuz marijuana is legal
here
oh yeah marijuana that's what
mild manner all right let's move on to
our next story Red Dead Redemption is
still coming out October 26 for ps4 and
Xbox one and I think somebody said to
say we're very excited to play it oh
yeah yeah the game it's probably gonna
be one of the biggest games this year
for sure oh yeah
without a doubt but this next story is
from Sony so basically we've already got
a bunch of really reveals so far sony
plans to reveal a bunch of games leading
up to e3 starting this Wednesday the 6th
so basically they're basically from
Wednesday to their press conference on
June 11th at 6 p.m. Pacific they will be
revealing a single thing per day on one
of their live stream channels so on live
PlayStation comm or on their twitch
account YouTube account Twitter account
Oh - sorry Facebook account and so on
June 6 they will announce a new ps4 game
with PlayStation VR support ok then on
the next day they will announce a
release date for an upcoming worldwide
studios title which I'm thinking dreams
that makes sense cuz this this could be
anything from one of their studios it's
something that's already been announced
right something has already been
announced and they wouldn't do like the
Last of Us part two they're saving the
main course for I could maybe see days
gone oh yeah okay and maybe see days
gone yeah dreams would make a little
more sense I think yeah for sure
so so that comes Thursday Friday we'll
get a new ps4 game that's all we've got
on that okay Saturday we're gonna get a
new PlayStation VR game okay and then
Sunday the day before e3 for Sony's
conference details for an eagerly
anticipated game that's coming to
PlayStation VR okay so again we already
know that's gonna get VR support uh III
don't know I don't know if this it it's
unclear it it makes me that's what I
feel right like it's gonna be like oh
here's like it may be like another
Resident Evil
seven thing where it's like Oh last of
us twos now got VR support exactly where
it's like a big core game but I think it
could just be hey you know that that
game that you're really excited for
PlayStation VR we're gonna show it's
gonna show more yeah that could also be
it so we'll see how that goes
but surprise Sony's going to reveal
PlayStation games so I'm actually not
that surprised now that I think about it
because they they kind of did this last
year I don't know if you remember this
right before their press conference they
had like a pre-show and actually
announced a bunch of stuff they showed
off I think they show it off like dreams
they they announced undertale for ps4
like before the press conference I
remember being like wow they're like
announcing stuff like that's crazy
and so for them to do it this year also
doesn't surprise me because they said
their press conference is going to be
primarily focused on those four core
games spider-man which we're looking at
right now then ghost of Toshima
Last of Us and des tranning so if
they're only focusing primarily on those
core four I'm sure we'll see some
trailers during the press conference but
it makes sense that like if they just
want to focus on those four they can get
some other announcements out of the way
early yeah absolutely and it'll be
interesting to see if they do last year
they had that like hour-long live stream
right before the press con right exactly
like I was saying yes yeah where they
just announced a bunch of stuff yeah
it'll be I wonder if they'll do that
again
yeah sony has gotten progressively more
and more just hey sit down shut up watch
these trailers right like last year
there was almost no talking yeah which
is like cool cool I kind of like a
little bit of talking yeah get your
message across a bit Ryan but but yeah
I'm it'll be interesting to see yeah I
hope I hope we see gameplay for Tsushima
ghosts of Tsushima so that'll be cool
that's the big focus they gotta ship
something for that yeah absolutely
so it'll be cool to see something from
that cuz I'm a big fan of sucker punch
right dude we're getting a sucker punch
game and an insomniac game right the
same around the same time hopefully and
dude like I don't know that we don't
know much about goes for Toshima but I'm
getting like a like I think about them
and
like open-world platforming games and
I'm like man this could be like a
stealth tenchu type of thing like
open-world tenchu game I could be really
really cool for sure and and it's just
like man we just haven't had like a big
open world Japanese small era yeah
that'd be really cool except for Yakuza
yeah cuz they oh yeah yeah totally
which never came out in the US bring
yaku's a Asian to the west
Sega I'm calling you out yeah I
someone's got to do it I just started
yak as a zero and I'm loving fans has it
is like didn't do much about Asian I
know that it is like all these
characters inexplicably Samurai
yeah like basically they're all
different characters but they're played
by the same oh it's not cause eeeh
yeah yeah he's like osseous sorry ah
here you carry you chasm oh yeah he's
like playing like a samurai and they're
they're all so it's like it reminds me
of those have you ever seen like a
sitcom or they'll have like an episode
but like let me tell you about when my
great-grandfather came on the Mayflower
start like that no no don't it doesn't
start like that but you know they do
that and then it cuts to like it's the
same characters playing people in the
past it's basically that and I love that
like that's a concept I think that's so
cool yeah that's all anyway that's
totally someone has to go off tangent
about Yakuza without Michael here oh
yeah I will be that person
yeah I I really like it I love I love
martial arts I love Japanese culture and
the eighties theme is just so cool yes
zero the 80s team is fans oh yeah I
playing Space Harrier like I played so
much space here it's like yeah oh man it
is it is a really cool series and I'm
glad I'm finally giving it a shot it is
something special
absolutely alright next story yeah so
for our next story we've got state of
decay to the patch patch 1.2 released
over the weekend and it is 20 gigabytes
large man Wow is freaking wild so sadly
state of decay too was a bit
disappointing it was a deeply I would
say so and this dispatch doesn't deliver
any content you you think with a patch
that size you think oh wow are they
adding
what are they adding this is like a lot
of fixes a lot of increases the ability
and network improvements okay some of
the big stuff is the elimination of
crashes due to being out of memory which
is a big thing oh yeah that seems like a
huge deal yeah but one of the funnier
ones is grenades no longer get stuck and
explode in front of client characters
face or behind their head while throwing
which which just sounds like something I
would do in real life I wish we had a
footage of that that'd be great
yeah I've never seen that but I want to
I want to see what that looks like yeah
I that that sounds hilarious but also
they're all so bad that should not be in
the game I don't think but but yeah that
that's that's that's kind of stuff
that's in this patch and it's studio
head Jeff strain said that this patch
today is just the beginning we have big
plans for state of decay too and we're
humbled and appreciative to you for
giving us the opportunity to make those
big plans happen so this is just the
beginning of their fixes like you you
actually played more of it than I did
right right yeah about like seven hours
or so and I liked it but it it kind of
were thin really quickly and then yeah
there were just like a lot of weird
issues I thought with the the UI and and
just like yeah some technical issues I
mean I was playing it on it X here in
the office and I ran decently well not
sixty though which you feel like it
could for kind of like the what the game
looks like wasn't like trying to plan a
home like my launch Xbox like it was
like oh not even know I had to play on
my PC if I wanted to play at home this
was just not possible in that original
launch so seeing that they're like
trying to fix like stability stuff is I
think the first step and then from there
I'd like to maybe see them hopefully
they could I would like to see them
address like UI stuff maybe they could
fix that a little bit and then just more
more stuff to do like more content more
more things like I'm glad they're
supporting it that feels like a trend
you know with games like nowadays is you
don't like just let a game die you do
your best to kind of like stick with it
and try and you know give a better
experience for the people who do really
like it and want more from that
so I'm glad they're doing that yeah that
that's it's it's cool to see a game not
get abandoned ranked and and in like
with Microsoft it's one of Microsoft's
marquee titles for the Xbox one it is
and don't really have much else right
now
I've it's been it's been hard to watch a
lot of Xbox games come out and like not
really deliver on what people hoped they
would be sure because as someone who
really appreciates their backwards
compatibility there right there cross
play all the stuff that they've been
doing that isn't necessarily the big
marquee thing you'd see at e3 I was
hoping you know let's get a win let's
get a win for Xbox I agree and people
say all the time like oh you guys hate
Xbox not true I am always rooting for
Xbox I want Xbox to succeed they're just
they're stumbling right now yeah like I
want to love Xbox cuz I actually think
they're backwards compatibility stuff is
awesome I think game pass is actually a
really smart idea like I think they're
doing a lot of stuff on like the program
like like service end of the Xbox
actually I think is better than
PlayStation they just don't have the
games right now
they need more yeah III is gonna be a
big a big stage for them right I'm very
excited to see what they're gonna show
cuz I feel like we don't know much about
them we kind of I feel like like Sony is
pretty much like told us exactly what
they're gonna show for the most part
yeah Microsoft is like a huge question
mark so I'm actually really excited for
those yeah it'll be interesting I mean
I'd be happy if they were just like
here's 50 new backwards incompatible
games but I feel like we need a little
more than that
I told you about my theory right what is
it
my-my like big bet because the last
couple years they've always had like a
big announcement like hey we're doing
game Pass hey we're doing backwards
compatible games are backwards
compatible compat and a lot of these
have online support but you can't play
them online because they shut down the
original Xbox server is back in 2011 I
believe my guess is they're going to
bring those servers back and they're
gonna let people play like you can now
play Crimson Skies online and we're
gonna make halo 2 backwards
bold crazy out there prediction is
they're gonna announce that I could see
that I I also hope that the I hope the
Ho Chi Minh where they make games run at
4k and faster frame rates um is applied
to everything
that'd be great I imagine it takes a lot
of work but that is so cool every time
they've done that with a game escape
three and and read dead like I saw some
when I got my xbox one X the first thing
I loaded up was skate three and I was
shocked I was just so genuinely shocked
by how good it looked because I was
expecting like okay to look right but it
it held up really well like yeah it was
it was completely wild I you know it's
it justified the purchase for me like I
really like playing old games having
them look that good on a big 4k TV just
unbeatable for me personally sure so
yeah that's that's that's that but you
know you were talking about state of k2
it just wasn't landing in all the right
ways fortunately Nam our review set as
much it said it took issue with the
technical faults but it was also like if
some of the stuff was a little more
engaging if there was more reason to be
here right they would be easier to
overlook so hopefully hopefully this
will make the experience that's already
there easier to get into yeah definitely
but here's hoping yeah that was our last
story for today yeah we got a whole 10
minutes yeah we got a whole 10 minutes
how are we going to do that well let me
tell you John Luke there's a special
game that came out this year that we
just had a review go up over the weekend
and it is by far my favorite game this
year definitely one of mine for sure and
it is the forest um
and Alessandro Barbosa who also wrote
our state of decay to review oh yeah
reviewed it and he loved it he gave it
an 8 out of 10 and it's uh it's it's
super man yeah you and I played through
the entire game together with
with our co-worker Jake Decker yep and a
little bit of Rob at the end yes a
little bit of Rob and it was it was an
amazing experience I really really
enjoyed it the storytelling where it
didn't fly get it it tells a story but
you never have to engage for the story
if you just want to play it like any
other survival game right but it funnels
you towards the end of this story by
giving you more tools it's kind of like
a Metroidvania yeah exactly and like
that that compelled me to play it I
don't like survival games that much like
I'm not a fan of roster arc and a lot of
the issues with that is that it's like
no goal for me at least like they like
the goal is supposed to be like you make
bigger better stuff but I just don't
personally find that that interesting
like I need a more narrative reason to
play something and the forest is like
you want to do this survival stuff so
that you can be prepared to explore and
find the story stuff and get that story
and I think like that on its own was
like a really like compelling reason to
like keep playing and it made me want to
like engage with it in a way that I feel
like other survival games have not done
for me
yeah it was I mean so for those who
don't know it is a game where you are in
a plane with your son and much like
Bioshock you crash but then a weird red
guy picks up your son and then runs off
with him and basically the story is you
have to find your son but you don't have
to you can just go make a house and live
in your house forever it's true yeah you
can you technically do that if you want
and it basically you you start off and
you're doing the survival thing you're
you're finding food you're drinking
water but then you start coming across
cannibals what you're seeing on screen
now and man they this game can be
freaking clear this games really creepy
even playing co-op the the review talks
about all centers review talks about how
the game's scarier solo and I would
agree with that for sure but I think
even depending if you're playing with
the right people even just playing like
the three of us you
really creepy to run into like caves and
stuff and there be times we're like oh
I'm gonna stay at the house and I'm
gonna chop wood while you guys go out
and explore and then like cannibals
would show up and I'm like on by myself
now oh no it like it just like that
dread it was so ah man I don't know like
I love this game yeah this game is so
cool it was really I mean like you were
saying like when we would split up yeah
that was some of the most tense moments
where we would where I'd be like okay
I'm gonna go off and get some stuff and
then like a friggin monster would show
up and I'm down like guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys guys get over here or we
would just see something cool and we
would all like Oh was that the was that
the house that we built that was just
like death every time we went to it no
that was the first house we did there is
some footage of that is okay and we made
this one house unfortunately it was like
we made it because it was right next to
this really major cave that we ended up
needing to go to a lot but it was also
right next to like a cannibal village
and it was like we can't ever stay here
they kept coming over asking for sugars
like hey it's like we don't got none and
then they would attack us because we
didn't have enough sugar yeah it's like
hey man this is our sugar we spent a lot
of time we crafted this sugar
yeah there's our first house pretty good
house and it was what a fantastic
experience and I highly recommend
everyone check it out it is it is it is
by far my favorite game this year and
I've played Gears I'm sorry I've played
God of War he played Gears I played
Gears of War this year for the first
time and this was better than that yeah
this this game was fantastic and even
better with friends the one thing that I
would criticize is that this is
something that you and I were both very
excited about because there's a
walkie-talkie right and it is the only
way to communicate with people online if
you're not using discord or Skype or if
you're just joining a random guys server
or not server but game you can open up
your walkie-talkie and talk to them sure
but there's no proximity chat exactly
yeah we were like hoping that it would
be this cool thing of like when you're
near each other you can hear each other
and if you're not you have
use the walkie-talkie and the thing is
when you hold up the walkie-talkie there
are other items you can't use and that
adds further tension yeah but
unfortunately it's like no no you can
only hear each other with the
walkie-talkie and that unfortunately
that's not great so I would love for
them the patch in like a proximity chat
oh yeah improve that yeah we ended up
you ended up just kind of cheating it
and using discord and which I would
recommend that wake something to trying
to use the walkie-talkies maybe too much
of a hassle yeah and if it would be cool
if if you know like we said if the
proximity chat was in because the
walkie-talkie does take up a spot but
where your torch would be so if you're
in a if you're in a cave and you want to
use your lighter to light up a torch you
can't talk to anyone while you're doing
that which is which I mean using a torch
in this game is crucial Oh totally you
should absolutely use a torch to see
anything and then of course you can get
a flashlight as you're seeing here
there's a bunch of items in here yeah it
was so cool every time you find a new
item oh man it's like whoa like this is
a game changer we have a flashlight now
yeah map now I have a chainsaw we have
and yeah it's man fantastic game I
highly recommend it especially if you
want to play with a couple friends you
can do up to eight I don't know if I'd
recommend eight that's a lot that would
probably suck all the tension away but I
think four is about we went up to 5 0 to
5 and definitely some of the tension was
gone from that yeah say like three or
four is probably the the best right to
do and it sorry someone called me a fake
for jitta fan and it caught it caught my
attention don't look at that no but yeah
the force was just a fantastic
experience and I I want to go back we've
we've convinced some people in the
office to plant play it with us for a
second time and we're just gonna like
kind of let them they're driving we're
just gonna be there or there for them
for support yeah Klee so go play the
forest go play the forest okay
also I'm forgiven an 8 out of 10 yep
it's good score yeah excellent score and
yeah that that's oh yeah this is Rob
just this is we had five people Rob is
just chainsawing and this is the moment
where it's like okay this is probably
like the tension is now gone yeah
but it was really funny oh yeah yeah and
that's another thing is it like we
replaced a lot of the tension with just
having an awesome time and laughing at
all this stuff and getting attacked by
camouflaged alligators which scare the
crap out of me but yeah but that's
that's what we've got for today yeah
play the forest is basically the
consensus of today's show yeah
everything else you said doesn't matter
play the forest yeah I I can't recommend
it enough it's it's it's truly truly
exceptional alright so that is the end
of the show you know what time it is it
is time to get more coffee I was gonna
say it's time to thank everyone oh yeah
we got to thank thank the coffee yeah
thank thank the coffee gods for bringing
it to us
thank Kali and Michael for holding it
down when I am at home writing the notes
they do an awesome job they're very busy
so we decided to help them out today yep
yeah busy III stuff keep an eye out for
all that good stuff all that good stuff
yes I want to thank Tony Tony for
helping out with the note in the back we
want to say Emily yep helps yes she got
us water today Thank You Emily for that
hey who normally set stuff up me as well
I set up stuff tonight I'd like to thank
John Luke for being here so I didn't
have to do the switching you know thank
you
wow I didn't want to say anything but
I'm glad you thank you
teaching me how to use a computer it was
awesome yeah and you did some notes too
as well so yeah yeah thank you for that
welcome yeah and thanks Chris Pereira
for always being our guy making sure we
we don't make any mistakes and yeah it's
uh we've got a great team and I'm so
happy to be a part of it yeah and stick
around because in a minute we're going
to have Rob and Jake are gonna be
playing Far Cry fives Vietnam DLC
expansion yeah they're gonna check
that's gonna be awesome yeah I'm
actually haven't seen anything I'm kind
of curious
I like Far Cry 5 so we'll have to not as
much as the forest though no all right
bye everybody
bye guys
you
you
you
you